hello and welcome to this video playing
not Larson I only play them three times
it's a surprising i think i played him a
lot with earlier accounts name is very
familiar okay we get Queens Queens no
rule oppressed exchange yeah I've had
problems with this in the past
especially the thing is against the real
exchange you have a couple of things
that you can play with John very sound
solid and okay but very difficult to do
anything with and if you play more
ambitiously you sometimes get yourself
into trouble and this is what I'm
constantly doing so I want to I just
play yeah play conservatively him and
see what happens not doing anything
fancy okay let's stop any analog if I've
is not really a threat and there's no
need to stop it ready so go here having
everything centralized I'm not so sure
got f4 from white it done this week and
II for quite a bit maybe I should have
played Bishop before if I think of it
but ok that's definitely a threat now we
should be for something that um he has
to react to somehow and of course does
not react to okay
yeah maybe okay maybe its place bishop
tea for something like that I still do
it
I mean if he has to play five this is
pretty bad now going Bishop f5 okay
maybe 54 I think I'm quite okay with
taking on c3 and then play be 65 ok so
those back hmm chirp g4 symbols but not
clear how much it does i think i'm
taking this this should be okay now try
for c5 in Bishop c6
yeah okay so he has to go e five now I
guess let's see you now h 5 h 4 and the
night over to f5 on I can also go down
immediately cc6 no one not so much that
defy this sum or would have been
interesting but no not anymore ok I can
go here though threatening to take k
okay let's move let's take this the
center
nothing to take f3 take III taking 5 4
porn
yeah yeah okay after cheat with the King
here I wouldn't have there's some
tactics like taking 93 rookie one no he
just gives me the pawn even though this
is not totally yeah it totally clear
everything and also has mean he has f5
let's see there
that's not easy not easy at all him how
to do that I probably have to be ready
to give stuff back King abrooke the aid
I cannot keep the pawn now king of 653
that looks wrong I have to be active ok
so what to do look here maybe Luke c3
feels very passive yeah if he goes rooks
III that he's in danger of getting zoosk
fault
I could move maybe who try to know I can
go here hmm yeah what dangerous is that
time learning f6 I can also ok I have to
check it anyway if 6i can also go to f7
okay let's see if I can grab all this if
you go through cage so I can still take
f6 and check on the tools to get the F
porn
o gauge okay what if you want think if
you want to do here h5 then g6 trying to
break through their cave no time
and he comes around down absolutely no
time
check 26 check
I know what this is but f1 seconds yeah
is this the problem one of the problems
jacket yeah technically I'm winning but
no time check check check check unbeliev
for what a lucky guy I mean I play Queen
B 1 and by chance he goes to be too yeah
okay anyway jab took took took too much
time quite quite obviously it's the main
the main thing happening here which
exactly did I fall into that time
pressure problem I was kind of okay time
was here check yeah I took a long time
he had it was tricky and it really was
tricky this end game with h4 h5 and this
is definitely risky maybe losing I don't
know my its its equal check check yeah
this is equal and until he oops no he
it's not equal rook h1 destroying way I
can tell if I have 10 seconds so he is
actually winning a few ghost king 25 hmm
very a bad time management around here
yeah that is not much I mean white white
definitely as worse here and question is
to maximize this but hmm yeah I didn't
get that much engine wants to play f6
here and and just break open the
position the reason why black is better
is that much better Bishop I on c6
compared to e3 maybe f6 yeah maybe I
mean it wasn't bad just again f6 cho-jen
yeah this is not I mean blacks better
but it's not winning and it also not a
clear advantage so I probably should
play one of those F success as the
engine suggests like this
and now play this position with that
like this in this just try to play a
middle game here with this terrible
bishop engine is pretty reliable in this
kind of open position that gives minus
0.9 0.8 something like that yeah that's
probably a better I mean I saw the
chances to win the pawn and she went for
it but in the process I'm trading off
the pieces all my better pieces for his
worst pieces so this is not not the
right way to do it you didn't the
endgame him this is some yeah it's it's
it's okay it's not winning or anything
he has this come to play for the pawn
Jenny wants to do this check then roped
you form and it looks pretty strong
hmm not sure even this is not clear if
it's winning it's probably close yeah I
was it was tricky very tricky okay
thanks for watching